right the four games it gets harder to
come up with six goats when there's only
four games but
i have my list i'm ready to go you have
to have six you have to come to the
table with six
in case you get the second pick you
gotta have three there's a chance you
take
mine i've never taken that risk of
having fewer than six ready to go so i'm
ready to go chris and i may get the
first pick who knows you got to answer
the trivia question right here it is
in the only bay of pigs playoff meeting
between the green bay packers and tampa
bay buccaneers it was the 1997
divisional round
who led all players in that game 1997
division around packers
buccaneers who led all players with
three sacks the packers won the game
21-7 right i remember watching the game
i mean
this is high school um i i remember the
day
specifically right it was kind of like a
foggy maybe a little drizzle
messy field right and that was the day
warren sapp and brett favre were talking
trash to each other a lot after plays
and doing that
i can't remember i'm gonna just go with
warren sapp
just because i feel like i remember yeah
baby
[Music]
99 qb killer whoa qb
killer that was one of the coolest
things i ever got from warren warren
sapp
he was sponsored by air jordan and you
know he had air jordan cleats
uh and he had qb killer
written on the side of them and he had
these high top air jordan patent leather
ones that
he never wore and i knew okay he might
be out of here this year he's going to
go to the raiders and be in the off
season so
he was kind of packing up his locker and
i was like man can i get one of those
cleats and
oh oh he go okay you know
get out of my face now get out of here
whatever you know
i kept them for a long long time they
were pretty cool
sap was always decked out in jordan gear
that's for sure
i tried to sell that question to you to
make you pick reggie white
i tried to emphasize that the packers
are yeah right yeah that's right trying
to get
i was trying to do that it didn't work
yeah nice try there slugger
nice try okay all right uh you get the
first pick
well i think it's a fairly easy one
this week i gotta go with drew brees uh
never liked talking about a hall of fame
first round you know first ballot hall
of famer like that
but drew brees i think is the the winner
of this award this week i think it's
fair to say with the way he played
and of course you know all three
interceptions being
really crucial but especially those
first two you know
just setting up short fields um
egregious
at you know of course and really put
them behind the eight ball in a lot of
ways but drew brees not playing well he
gets to go to the weekend
yeah you know i i definitely on my list
uh for me though i go to that saints
game and i look at how the saints had an
opportunity to get up
early yeah and to maybe deliver an early
knockout blow to the buccaneers when
deontay harris returned the punt for a
touchdown but oh
it was called back because carl
granderson
uh illegally blocked a buccaneers player
in the back you take that block away now
i don't know would the tackle have been
made if he hadn't illegally blocked him
i don't know sometimes yes sometimes no
but granderson's the guy
whose number was called although they
actually called the wrong guy there's a
guy that came in over the top afterward
who got
who got the public shame it was actually
carl granderson
who committed the illegal block and took
that six points off the board for the
saints yeah
that was uh definitely big you're right
about that and then losing
devante harris all together
was a big blow to their football team
with some of those two early plays he
made to set up their team the right way
you know i usually don't do this
but i'm gonna do it right here i'm gonna
go the rams defense the whole defense
goat sorry you usually don't do it you
do it all the time for goat drafts i
usually pick one guy for a goat draft
the goat draft i'm usually good at just
singling out one guy
this one i'm gonna give it to the whole
unit i am this it's the number one
defense in football
packer scored 32 points really probably
should have scored over 40.
i mean honestly the game could have been
a lot got out of hand a lot earlier than
that the packers kind of blew some of
those opportunities
but you know number one scoring defense
number one in yards allowed
and the packers rack up 484 yards of
total offense
throw it and run it both ways and
execute
all game long and do whatever they want
i have so much respect for that rams
defense but
you know again it's the playoffs but
they need to play special in that
football game and they didn't do that so
they're go they're goaterized
but look at all those great players they
have you can't come up with one name
you don't have one player fine i can go
uh i'll take i'll take aaron donald i
don't know jayla
he was injured i know i don't care one
of them's got to make a play i don't
know i'm trying to i'm trying to lead
you in a different direction here i'm
trying to say the guy who ended up
getting rewarded with a head coaching
job maybe should have been the one
wearing the goat horns guy who's
responsible for pulling the defense sure
brandon stalin
maybe he's the one that's trying to
that's that's fair to say there's no
doubt
there may be a point in that game where
you go hey brandon staley
like we gotta change it up or you might
have to take a chance and blitz and do
something a little different here
because rogers was in the groove all
game long and really the only thing that
was messing them up was
really just them themselves not not the
rams
let me just be clear since we have a
pending interview request with brandon
staley
you're the one who said it not me all
right ram's defense
well well we've got while we've got uh
coaches uh with the goat horns i'm gonna
go with andy reid
very simple reason i love you andy reid
and you're one of the great coaches of
all time you'll be in the hall of fame
you got your ring you may get another
one what are you doing running patrick
my home's on third and one with a bad
toe what are you doing
now look it's not like he he knew he was
going to get a concussion but you threw
him into harm's way with an impaired
foot
and oh lo and behold he got a concussion
so yeah the the result
justifies the the uh punishment and the
punishment is
goat in a bad way coming out of weak uh
division around even though they won
that that's the only thing you know to
me worth questioning is just that right
like just yeah he's got to hurt toe
um but as we've seen he's not afraid
to run my homes and do those things in
short-yardage situations
you know we saw it in the super bowl
last year against the the 49ers
we saw it earlier in this football game
where he scored a touchdown
on the same exact play he got hurt on
it's the same play
so uh yeah just you know tough break
weird injury like we talked about
and i i don't
there's not a lot of obvious goats this
week in this draft
but yeah i mean i i it's
i want to go either the center or the
ravens or just lamar i'll go lamar
i'm going to throw lamar in the goat
draft right here just for the pick six
i don't like to do it i'm gonna do it
right now though just because it was a
big moment and lamar needed to make a
big play with his right arm
and he stared down his favorite receiver
and tyron johnson made an unbelievable
play but
uh i guess i'll go with him because of
the magnitude of the moment
the questions about his ability to
dissect teams when he does have to throw
the football
that was big and he let the team down
there the last one for me and
i knew i could save it to the end
because there was no way that you
would take it i don't know who it is but
whoever came up with the
worst rule in football the stupid ass
fumble the ball out of the end zone and
the other team gets the ball under 20.
whoever came up with that rule is the
goat and i still don't know
who came up with it why they came up
with it because it fits within
everything else in football no one fits
perfectly you know what you you're the
only one who says that when i asked
people connected to the league they're
like i don't know it was like that when
i got here
i had some people in the league
yesterday text me god never thought of
that after i heard your argument you've
kind of persuaded me so maybe they need
to listen to me more
no no but but the thing that they the
fact that they didn't already know that
after years and years of using the rule
tells you they're just grasping for
justification now because your argument
frankly and i love you your arguments
suck oh my god you don't have an
argument you have nothing
yeah you have none it sucks my argument
i love you and
we know there's lots of idiots in this
league so i'm not gonna sit here and bow
down to them and go oh
because they didn't think about it we
should change the whole freaking game
there's idiots all over this leagues
sorry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports